نحن نقف الان هنا في مخيم جباليا شمال قطع
غزه حيث الوضع الانساني يزداد سوءا يوما
بعد يوم مع تفاقم هذه الازمات وتفاقم
معاناه المواطنين في ظل منع الاحتلال دخول
اي مساعدات او دخول اي مواد اساسيه
للاستمرار في الحياه حيث اصبح الاهالي هنا
يقومون بطحن طعام الحيوانات وطعام الدواب
لتحويله الى خبز وس جوعهم هنا في شمال
قطاع غزه كما نشاهد هنا
هذا طعام الدواب وهذه الذره التي تستخدمها
العائلات في شمال قطاع غزه من اجل سد
جوعهم المياه قاعدين احنا بنشرب مياه
ملوثه الاكل ملوث احنا قاعدين هذا هذه
الذره اللي قاعدين بنبيع في الدول الثانيه
لا تصلح للاستعمال الحيواني مش لدمي احنا
قاعدين
بنستعملها الناس مضطره انها تجنوا وتخبز
وفي بيزبط مهم وفي ما بيزبط معاهم احنا
الان في مجاعه رسميه
وحقيقيه احنا في بيئه متلوثه
100% احنا مياه ما في ته لا في ميه ولا في
اكل ولا في شرب ولا في قمح القمح لا
يستعمر فقط للدواب هذا للدواب هي اللي
هذا زبل مش ذ اوب يا رب هين بدي انخل انا
منه و بفرجيك ايش اللي بتخل اللي بتخل سوس
وتنخل دود وتنخل حشرات منه ما بتنخ
طحين هذا هو هي عندك 2 كيلو هي اقل من 2
كيلو هي
زبله يعني قاعدين احنا بناكل زبل ما بناكل
اكل
اوادم
وما بتاكل اصلا البنادمين تع الحيوانات
بنسويها الحين بنحمص و بناكله من القله من
الجو جعانين احنا الكبار جعانين والاطفال
جعانه كمان ما فيش ولا شغل ولا عمله ولا
حاجه ولاقينا اشتريه في السوق ما فيش ولا
اكل ولا شرب والاولاد كله قاعد من وين
يطلعوا يشتغلوا ببر الدود منه والمعفن
لانه وصيته ميه مش قادرين نشتريه لقول
اولاد عشارع بالبال جابوه لموه قلت لهم
حمسو وبر الدود والوسق منه عشان اطحن
واطعمك اولاد ابني اولاد بنتي كلهم عندي
من وين اجي من وين 50 نفر عيلتي في الصف
ولا عندي غطاء اتنفا فيه ولا اكل ولا شرب
ولا حاجه من ولا شي احنا 200 من الجو عصلا
بشتغل بنظف الجم اكل الدواء من الحشرات
والمبيدات
والوسخ وبنط حنه وبنعمل خز كله جعانين
اكثر حاجه جعانين انت شا ايش بنساوي بنطول
الدود وبنعمل طحين وبناكل مع انه مش زاكي
بس بدنا نصبر حالنا على
الجوع هكذا وصل الحال بالاهالي هنا في
شمال قطاع غزه في ظل منع الاحتلال دخول
المواد الاساسيه ومنع الاحتلال دخول
المساعدات اصبح الاهالي يستخدمون طعام
الحيوانات وطعام الدواب اكرم الله من اجل
سد جوعهم وجوع اطفالهم هنا في شمال غزه
انس الشريف الجزيره شمال
غزه